hey there reject nation look we got we
got an official new background oh
i thought the other one looked too nice
i said now that i got a new place
just need three items hung half-assedly
thought it was perfect that was really
really rested against more than 100. now
it's been kind of a crazy week um
realizing that with everything coming
out next week when i have to move the
one time was up for like 40 hours but it
was exciting we got a whole bunch of
boxes everywhere we did some
soundproofing with the place we got more
to do so yeah it's more echoey than
usual but i was thinking we gotta watch
this trailer because if you watch our
reaction to the finale of stranger
things we skipped the preview because we
just wanted to focus on the episode
itself
no i don't want to watch a preview no
i'm already committed i'll be there
now we're here to watch that preview
it's only like 30 seconds long
apparently but hey figure perfect new
video to watch and what kind of channel
would real rejects be
if we waited to do a new video when
everything's ready to go and set up
that's just not our style we're never
going to change never stop never stop
we're so humble
all right john
let's show them how to react
absolutely get ready for the ruling of
your life
[Music]
it is over 11.
you have freed me
you can't stop this now
i am so excited
you know what else was shown a couple
months ago i was thinking about it that
shot would hopper with the flamethrower
that never came into play whoa whoa whoa
whoa okay so as i'm cutting this up
right now what i just noticed is
i missed it the first time is that
hopper is it and it's looking at tanks
full of demogorgons i imagine that
they're not just you know demogorgon's
caught and then being kept there being
preserved i imagine that maybe somehow
the russians are trying to you know
duplicate them reproduce them in some
way and then figure out a way to control
them so they have like an army on their
hands so what hoppers do with the
flamethrower it's kind of like some
ripply alien [ __ ] and it's gonna go in
there and torch all them
yeah that's what i just figured out i
think this was gonna happen
and the other big one is eddie playing
guitar mad max style in the upside down
which has me theorizing because he's
talking about in the final episode how
you know like he doesn't consider
himself to be a hero that maybe you know
they can't find a way to play nancy's
favorite song but he happens to know how
to play nancy's favorite song so he has
to go into the upside down and play it
that's my best guess or he's bored out
of his mind it just goes into the other
side he's gonna practice the final
episode two hours and 45 hours so
he's just like screw it just throw him
in there and have a guitar perfect yeah
he's vectors music slayed we're going
off with the footage that we got here
you know you have vecna at the top
saying it is over 11 you have freed me
we haven't seen anything yet right in
volume one that suggests that
he she freed him i don't know what's
happening john i don't either i mean
maybe it's just yeah like all of this
battling with the upside down and all
the things that we've seen unfold over
the past three seasons maybe in part two
he's going to transcend the upside down
in his true form and come back into our
world instead of you know like warping
people from the other side inside out
and all that stuff i could foresee it
being something like that where it's
like the evil is actualized into you
know the actual full-on earth realm at
least from what the trailer is
suggesting too it doesn't look like that
hopper joyce and murray are gonna be
going back to the states by the end of
the season it looks like that everything
connected to the upside down on their
side of the story is gonna remain in
russia yeah yeah and then maybe by the
end of the season we'll get that little
tease of them finally heading for home
or something like that
and i love too how the stuff in russia
like it almost started to remind me of
like a resident evil game because it's
like oh clearly they've got more going
on here than just the one demogorgon
they had to take out this is probably
going to get a whole lot worse and it
makes a lot of sense then the way we
leave them off joyce hopper and murray
you know kind of just at the personal
resolution rather than any of the you
know resolution of the circumstances and
the stakes i think the thing the the big
question has been who's gonna die this
season i think with stranger things they
used to play it pretty safe but i it was
either sean levy or one of the duffer
brothers who said that the value 2 was
going to like break our hearts so that
usually implies there's going to be some
type of massive debt some type of really
big debt i feel like it's gonna be steep
steve seems like the one the character
who would probably be the one to be
killed off because the guy out of anyone
is always looking for some sense of
like purpose out of the kids he just
never seems to really get higher in life
never seems in any way
with his own peers or anybody above his
station he's mostly yeah just big
brother steve and that would hurt and i
feel like he would he is set up to like
give him like some house give a big
sacrifice to help others survive yeah
and i mean i guess that would make sense
for how his story is unfolded this
season and and the ways in which you
know he's drifted
even though his emotional journey hasn't
been one of the most engaged so far i
mean you know it does seem like he is
sort of drifting apart with his friends
although i keep hoping that maybe that
whole thing about dustin idolizing him
will have a hopeful foreshadowing
quality to it although i feel like it
just goes to support your theory well
also for sure paul ryder is going to die
yeah he's going to i've been saying he's
going to die since the first time we've
got confirmation he's coming back in
this season yeah he's for sure dying
that's going to be his you know his the
balancing of the scales for him allowing
this horribly necessary process with 11
to happen the way it has happened and um
look click off now if you don't want
leaks but i did read some plot leaks
it's not like me to read plot leaks for
shows
but um basically mike and will end up
hooking up because will shows up going
mike you know i've been in such a [ __ ]
mood because you forgot it was my
birthday yes and then mike's like i'm
sorry i i here i i got a present for you
and then he just goes in and lays a big
fat tongue in his mouth and then 11
shows up and then kills mike
and will yeah at the same time same time
it is brutal to my understanding yeah
yeah and this is all official confirmed
plot leaks released by netflix
themselves this is canon all of it so
guys you can take my word for it this is
all 100 gonna come true
and if you guys think i'm being
sarcastic
think again this is all
true
facts facts
facts you made this video weird i hope i
can save it by the editing
definitely will definitely absolutely
it's like we've been non-stop for many
many hours with no sleep and then we
decided we should roll the camera hey
it's good to be back with you guys and
the space will keep evolving like a
living breathing organism until finally
it is even better than it was before
how cool of a set would that be
just
it
to develop it becomes sentient
just
develops itself to be gross and we
mix it up it does it on its own it
evolves and then if we try to change it
then it fights back and yeah it's full
yeah it's like a horrible black mirror
room where it starts changing itself to
disconnect call the movie
the set the set
oh
there's something there stranger sets
the setting
it wants to be said to be
stationary and not changed it wants to
be set dressed
it wants to be decorated
all right guys
craig's done
john i'm always done